pour en parler nous sommes avec denis
barbarossa experts compte à co fondateur
d'à complice bonsoir dénis et barbarossa
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors vous les experts comptables
vous avez fait votre propre étude
d'impact les résultats finaux seront
dévoilés en mars 2020 est ce que vous
avez déjà une première voilà impression
à la lumière de cette étude
bonsoir aujourd'hui on a effectivement
une grosse inquiétude on a commencé à
chiffrer a essayé de poser beaucoup de
questions puisqu'on était assez intrigué
par les promesses gouvernementales
beaucoup de deux gagnants et des
perdants théoriquement quand on commence
à simuler un petit peu différemment se
rend compte qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
de perdants en tout cas chez indépendant
et on a eu beaucoup de 2,2 des changes
avec le gouvernement ce qui nous a
effectivement poussé à lancer cette
étude au niveau de l'accueil avec notre
caisse de retraite
la québec a souhaité lancer une étude
pour mieux comprendre avec six autres
caisses de retraite de professions
libérales pour challenge est un petit
peu les études de lancé par le
gouvernement et comprendre comment
autant de gagnants pouvait coûter aussi
cher en fait dans un régime qui se
voulait équilibré et dans une promesse
de coût identique pour le concitoyen est
donc premier peut-être premières
impressions de ses études ou rire
d'infiltrer pour l'as pas encore de le
filtre effectivement sur le sur le sujet
donc les spécialistes se sont réunies on
commença à eux devraient également les
consoeurs et confrères fait expert
comptable on demandait en fait à pouvoir
contribuer à apporter leur pierre à
l'édifice que je salue c'est une très
bonne initiative que vouloir rester bon
contribuer aux côtés des spécialistes
une fois encore on est quand même
dubitatif en fait sur le sur le mode de
financement puisque on a de nouvelles
promesses notamment d'un minimum
vieillesse très fortement augmenté
ça ne se fait pas sans son coût
complémentaire en tout cas son
cotisation complémentaire donc sans
revenus diminuer pour ceux qui cotisent
aujourd'hui alors votre indignation de
la part des experts comptables mais pas
que évidemment le parlement qui vote
aujourd'hui le texte mais finalement son
savoir combien cela va coûter
c'est à dire que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui vous nous dites vous n'a
aucune idée
vraiment de ce que ça va coûter
complètement concrètement une étude
d'impact qui fait plus de 1000 pages
aujourd'hui qui ne permet pas à tout à
chacun de prendre la mesure en fait des
enjeux avec beaucoup de simulations
beaucoup de chiffres qui ont été
communiqués
les chiffres une fois encore qu'ils ne
nous paraissent pas cohérent tout cas le
peu que nous avons testé sur ce qui nous
concerne démontre que les chiffres
effectivement d'étude d'impact ne sont
pas tout à fait juste et cohérent donc
il est quand même compliquée aujourd'hui
je pense pour un députés de se prononcer
sur un texte aussi engageant il n'engage
pas que la majorité actuelle et le
gouvernement actuel il engage que même
la profession et la france et nos
concitoyens sur les 40 prochaines années
pour les cotisants et 20 ans de retraite
c'est quand même un enjeu très important
ne prend pas le prendre à la légère ces
14 % de pib c'est 360 milliards d'euros
de dépenses
ça ne suppose quand même ça suppose un
minimum de travaux et d'études
préalables alors vous avez aussi un
cours ou au personnel un chez les
experts comptables vous cotisez déjà
pour un régime particulier mais vous
devrez également cotiser pour ce régime
universel l'instar un petit peu d des
avocats où en est votre combat est ce
que vous êtes entendus par le
gouvernement
entendu on l'est tous aujourd'hui je
pense que gouvernement effectivement
fait preuve d'une entente de certaines
donc il reçoit beaucoup il est il entend
une ex-top ils ont des pleurs en fait un
manque d'écouté n'a pas du gouvernement
qui effectivement reçoit nous entend
mais n'écoute pas en tant que tel les
débats que nous pouvons avoir joué les
craintes de la profession
ces craintes sont justifiées aujourd'hui
on a assimilé aujourd'hui des coûts très
largement supplémentaires je l' ai déjà
dit à votre antenne d'années on a 20 %
d'augmentation de nos cotisations
minimum et 10% traduction delà de nos
pensions ce qui est effectivement un
sujet très important nous cotisons déjà
à la société nationale donc nous
cotisons de l'ordre de 100 millions
d'euros pour la profession des
experts-comptables donc vingt mille
personnes cotisent au niveau déjà de la
solidarité pour des sommes assez
importantes
nous ne sommes pas contre un régime
universel le régime de points nous
sommes déjà dedans donc c'est un système
que l'on connaît qui al'avantage
effectivement de sa simplicité pour tout
à chacun de comprendre combien le stock
de points est acquis et donc quelle est
sa valeur pour eux pour demain le
problème de fond c'est qu'on n'a pas la
valeur du point aujourd'hui on fait des
prévisions sur sur des bases
complètement incertaine on ne sait pas
comment évaluera évoluera ce point
puisque en fait on entendu dire la
semaine dernière que finalement on
verrait bien un nouvel indice
arrivé et nous sommes effectivement très
circonspect sur la méthodologie
aujourd'hui et la durabilité en fait de
cette loi c'est l'inquiétude voulait
formule est évidemment puisqu'on vous le
dit vous êtes entendu qu est ce qu on
vous répond concrètement quand on vous
avez une personne en face qui représente
au gouvernement elle vous dit quoi
il faut être solidaire nous sommes déjà
qu'il faut prendre le courage d'avoir
des réformes ambitieuses pour nos
concitoyens et solidaire une fois encore
la réforme sans aucun doute une fois
encore nous sommes pour la réforme mais
nous sommes pas pour cette forme de
réformes qui nous paraît pas tout à fait
plausible aujourd'hui absolument pas
chiffré ce qui nous pose un véritable
sujet ou encore vu les enjeux importants
et et surtout troupes trop mal préparés
en fait concrètement alors on a entendu
évidemment beaucoup de professions se
manifester les danseuses les danseurs de
l'opéra de paris les avocats
vous êtes plutôt une profession assez
discrète quels sont vos moyens
d'attendre pour vendre d'actions par
donc on vous faire entendre et surtout
écouter c'est tout le sujet la
profession qui effectivement a
finalement assez peu de moyens de
pression aujourd'hui à linverse de nos
amis avocats que je salue pour leur
courage et leur engagement
nous n'avons pas de lieux comme le
palais pour nous retrouver et faire
caisse de résonance nous avons une
mission d'intérêt général une mission
légale également que de respecter et
faire respecter la loi donc on ne peut
pas se permettre de ne pas faire de
déclarations pour le compte de nos
clients
par contre effectivement certains
commencent déjà aujourd'hui à émettre le
souhait de revenir une déclaration
papier à revenir également aux tchèques
pourquoi pas pour freiner en fait
l'encaissement et gêner un petit peu la
tutelle c'est ça fait parti d'un d'un
des propositions que l'on peut entendre
ici et là on voit ce une profession
effectivement assez citoyenne et et
droite dans la volonté de servir et
continuer à rester au service certes de
l'état puisque nous sommes une
profession sous tutelle de deux clients
avant tout qu'ils restent nos donneurs
d'ordres pour vous aujourd'hui la
mobilisation elle va se jouer ou sur le
terrain comme on l'a vu en décembre avec
des blocages du pays notamment dans les
transports elle va se jouer au parlement
c'est que ça s'annonce assez compliquée
avec ses milliers
et quarante mille amendements quelle
peut être l'issue pour vous je n'ai pas
de boule de cristal et je suis donc en
moins on commet députés donc j'ai pas la
la la la
l'oreille aujourd'hui et la capacité en
fait à comprendre un petit peu comment
aujourd'hui que vivent ce bouleversement
très important que nos concitoyens ont
vécu et que la france aujourd'hui a vécu
depuis comme de nombreux mois ce que
nous demandons tout cas nos consoeurs et
confrères c'est d'informer très
massivement notamment les députés pour
leur faire prendre conscience des enjeux
de la réforme et conscience des risques
volet qui pèsent sur cette réforme
nous avons déjà un modèle de courrier
que nos syndicats l'ifac institut
français d expert comptable et
commissaire aux comptes a communiqué à
ma profession pour faire en sorte que
massivement la profession se mobilise et
écrivent à ses députés pour leur faire
prendre conscience des enjeux c'est pour
nous jouer le meilleur le meilleur atout
que de faire prendre conscience aux
députés de l'importance des textes qui
sont sous lé aujourd'hui et de
l'incohérence de certaines de certains
chiffres comment vous avez réagi au
départ de la ministre bus a changé un
finalement pour vous c'est plutôt un
mauvais signal
c'est un sujet complexe les retraites il
est complexe de se mettre dans ce sujet
aussi lourd aussi aussi important d'un
point de vue mathématique d'une part et
d'engagement pour le pour la préfète
pour le pour l'état un changement en ce
moment sur les sujets aussi l'eau n'est
pas évident sans aucun doute même si le
secrétaire d'état en fait fait tout son
travail sur son sujet en tant que tel
les enjeux de la ministre était
important et il me paraît crucial dans
ces cas là de mettre au moins en sommeil
la retraite le récent pendant le temps
que chacun puisse effectivement retrouvé
un petit peu ses marques et prend le
temps d'une vraie discussion
il ya eu dans la concertation qui était
plutôt un temps d'écouté de la part de
nos gouvernants il serait peut-être
temps maintenant d'aller vraiment dans
le dur de sujets de comprendre que les
français sont inquiets sur cette réforme
et que les professions libérales
également sont très inquiètes des
propositions qui ont été faites et qui
ne tiennent pas compte une fois encore
de ce que l'os et les propose nous avons
aujourd'hui beaucoup de propositions
pertinentes de la part de nos voisins
européens la france se fait toujours
fort de vouloir innover différemment on
a su innover en 54 tva est un impôt que
le monde nous envie aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas l'être la forêt de certains
impôts qu'on serait qu'une réforme que
se sont vus quand on voit les résultats
dans la rue merci beaucoup denis
barbarossa d'avoir été
avec nous